[Music]
you're listening to episode 17 of
storycast21 i'm jane secker
on a quiet monday in 2004 a separated
father from gloucestershire dressed up
as a superhero before taking a dramatic
course of action that would change his
life and the lives of his children this
is batman raids buckingham palace
[Music]
my name is martin brunt i'm skye's crime
correspondent
it was a monday afternoon 13th of
september 2004
and we were suddenly told that batman
had broken into buckingham palace
it's supposed to be one of the most
secure buildings in the world but yet
somehow this happened
a campaigner conspicuously dressed
managed to reach the balcony of
buckingham palace despite the presence
of armed guards
[Applause]
my name is jason hatch
so the lad just pulled off and the
ladder like i said ladder was going
towards the building as it's going
towards the building i've already
climbed um robin's behind me now he's
got the pack lunches he's got the drinks
he's got the sandwiches he's got it all
in the backpack i've got the banner and
that's all i've got jason hatch from the
group fathers for justice then climbed
onto the ledge evading capture and
sparking a massive security alert
of course i make it up
for a while i just
froze i thought do i do it here do i
just um unveil the banner yeah so i
thought no so i kept going now as i'm
going
more
guards and the police are coming ate
he was a
disgruntled distraught father who for
some years had found it very difficult
to get access to his children after his
divorce so he was representing
a growing organization called fathers
for justice
we thought if we do this yeah it's going
to be on the news um if we get away with
it
i honestly really didn't think it'd be
as big as what it was
[Music]
um i'm from cheltenham born and bred
i've always been a painter and decorator
since leaving school
and i'll still continue doing that to
this day
um it was two it was two days two to
three days before the the 9 11
disaster um
so i come home
from working away and uh put the key in
the door open the door and the ace was
empty
i called my ex to find out where she was
she said she'd gone and left with the
children and that's when all my troubles
started
i've got an eldest son i've always seen
him
uh
then i had two other children with my
ex-wife there was
two
and one at the time when
when she left
she just never ever turned up to
any of the contact
every week i'd be there because i kept
saying to me this time she hadn't turned
up oh you've got to go you've got to
keep make sure you turn up and of course
we'll be sat there for an hour
just watching cars come by and this uh
and yeah um
i just had a brick wall with it to be
fair
and on saturday this man brought the
london eye to a standstill by climbing
to the top while dressed as another
superhero just after then is when i
started up with fathers for justice the
group was set up by fathers who feel
they've been treated unfairly by courts
in custody battles
fathers for justice was a protest group
that campaigned for equal access to
children equality
between
mothers and fathers the style of their
campaigning is clearly designed to
capture maximum publicity
fathers of justice i think the first
time it was a clifton suspension bridge
in bristol
we closed that one down
and i stayed up for
27 hours upon the bridge
um that was my first arrest
and then after that
i stopped counting at 49 times
and there was several more after that
campaigners recently highlighted lack
security at the house of commons they
pelted tony blair with purple flower
bombs prompting fears of a biological
attack
i wonder why
order this house is no suspended
we had two guys that were on trial for
the purple pada
on tony blair and gordon brain
and so we thought well
let's do something
that we can get the support from our
guys they're in london
and we need to go bigger than the ages
of parliament
[Music]
so okay there's only one place you can
go bigger
and that's birkeland palace
why buckle and palace and the queen
when you're in family courts behind the
judge is a crest and that's the queen's
quest so all the orders that he's given
out
is on her name
so
it all fitted together okay
buckingham palace
we've got a friend that lives in nyla
dogs and um he's a he's an activist
himself
and so we stayed there with this map
uh this bird's eye view map of
buckingham palace and it's like are we
gonna do it then
and i looked at it and i thought there's
that's a flat roof there if we put the
ladder up there
that's going to make publicity a little
bit
i said so
let's do it that way
batman for me was that was the last film
i watched with my son
it's a bit of humor
it's a bit of tongue-in-cheek
but you know you walk past the building
your kids say oh look mommy daddy you
know there's a super on the building
so we look at it like that and we think
yeah that's fine then you've got it all
sort of
every dad is a child superhero in one
way my dad's better than yours no your
dad's better than mine
and uh a few people said they're gonna
shoot you you'll you'll never get away
with that and i said well look
i haven't got my children so i've got no
there's no point in me living i said
because they've taken away everything
that means anything to me they were in
my life they've took it away so we've
got to go with it
[Music]
it's a very secure building there are
cctv cameras an alarm system
bulletproof windows
there's a very high 14 foot high
perimeter wall
fencing with spikes and barbed wire
and armed guards
so go there and have a look and we pull
over
and there's just these coach loads of
armed guards just driving in into the
past like
this is an insane idea to try and do
this
this
be a big one
we're in the back of the van costumes
getting ready for the costume noise that
i've been coats on
we had another activist guy eddie bless
him driving the van
and all of a sudden he found the van go
on boys go go go so jumps out the back
of me van
so the lad just pulled off
and the ladder i said ladder was going
towards the building as it's going
towards the building i've already
climbed
jason hatch the protester was dressed in
black boots black mask black cape a
yellow and black batman motif on his
chest
it looked more like the sort of cheap
fancy dress costume you would buy
at a shop to go to a party robin's
behind me now he's got the packed
lunches he's got the drinks he's got the
sandwiches he's got it all in the
backpack
i look down and there's a guy there with
a gun he's saying stop or i'll shoot
stop i'll shoot
and of course i make it up
and i look behind and i see dave getting
back down
dave pike um he's robbing all of my uh
protest
i thought well i can't go back now
so i kept going now as i'm going that
more more
guards and the police are coming out
so before i ever go and then so i start
going along this ledge and i'm stepping
on bird wire and also this guy puts his
arm through like this doorway which is
it's got to be roughly where i think the
queen's bedroom is and he grabs over me
and i said mate get off you know the
father suggested i'm shouting fathers
for justice
and with that he let go
and as he let go i carried on and i
thought i'll run real the banner i was
still quite distance away from the
balcony
but then i looked at the balcony
and there's nothing stopping me from
where i was to the balconies oh okay
i carried onto the balcony
i had the banner made in chatham
and it said fathers for justice
superhero dads
it looked good it did look good
[Music]
it's supposed to be one of the most
secure buildings in the world but yet
somehow this happened
a campaigner conspicuously dressed
managed to reach the balcony of
buckingham palace despite the i was
sitting at my office in westminster and
saw it on the newswires and headed
straight down there i didn't have far to
go but
it was a security breach
it was an iconic building and we were
desperate to find out what the police
were going to do and exactly what the
intruder was up to the 33 year old was
helped by this man who was dressed as
batman sidekick robin
my kids are worth it he was arrested by
police but only after he'd given
interviews to the media i'm on the ledge
now and the security of command because
obviously they thought i was going to
come into the palace like no i'm just
here to do a protest on fathers for
justice
and he said how long are you going to be
here and i said i want to tell the news
at five i said that when i made the news
at five i said i'll come off
and uh
he said mate he said you've gone on
every channel around the world
but we're going to turn now to a major
security concern at buckingham palace
this morning a man scaling a fence to
get inside the queen's home in one of
the most serious incidents there in
decades abc's nick striffin is outside
it's very unusual for anybody to break
into the palace grounds but for batman
to do it this iconic
cartoon character to do it
made it even more enticing as a story
who knew then how it was going to unfold
it's supposed to be one of the most
protected buildings in the world
yet all it took to spark a massive
security alert was one determined
protesters
i've been there about a thing i've been
about an hour and a half now two hours
and a guy turned around and said to me
um
if you come down now and come on in
there's somebody in here who wants to
speak to you
yeah yeah i said is it my children and
he said no i said tell him i don't want
to speak to him there and with that
prince charles looked rained i'm afraid
that i believe that we delude ourselves
if we think that humanity is becoming
ever more reasonable it's simply not the
case
he had a suit on in a tie and uh
he had a bit of a grin on his face
because obviously he got batman
literally
talking to him through these curtains
we got there and we couldn't get as
close to the palace as we wanted to
there were already lots of police
once it was realized that there was
something exciting going on um there
were quite a few people gathering but
the police trying to keep us back
and throughout
our live coverage viewers could get a
glimpse of jason hatch clinging to the
palace wall
and attempts by police and others
leaning over
the balcony to try to talk him down
my mum said she was shopping with a
friend
and uh a friend had a telephone call and
she said um
margaret we got we got to go on we might
say well i finished doing me shopping
yet said no we really do need to go home
we need to go home now
and so she rushed my mum back home to
put the television on
officers are continuing to urge his
companion to come down and although the
queen is not in residence
and she said who's
he couldn't really stand forward he had
to lean against the stonework
and the
people trying to talk him down were
hanging over the balcony of the palace
he could easily have fallen to his death
and with live cameras
covering every moment of this the
authorities certainly didn't want to be
seen to be causing him any any real harm
but with the um uh ambulance team they
they said look you know we can see
you're you've dehydrated you've been up
here i think it's about four and a half
hours at this time he said look we need
to get you a drink
uh if we get your drink you drink it i'm
thinking yeah you've put something in it
and you know you're gonna grab me and
he's look i promise you he said i
promise you he said i swear i won't put
anything in it so we come out with a
bottle of lucas aid and that bottle of
lucas 80 turn around he said that is
from the queen's fridge so actually i
bought the lucasait from the queen's
fridge
you know i had people like the front
sighting go on batman and of course the
crate was picked up by this time and
there was a load of horns going off in
i still didn't realize i still didn't
think i bigger actually went
buckingham palace security is supposed
to be top notch but this morning we're
learning a man was able to scale the
12-foot wall oil security was recently
overhauled after a daily mirror reporter
got a job at buckingham palace as a
servant one of the most serious security
breaches here in more than 30 years and
this morning police aren't ready
all i want to do is see my children
and basically
father's rights children's rights
to change in this in this country
the head of security which obviously i
was talking to him saying to him look
this you know i want to see my children
and he's going yeah he sympathize with
you and i said yeah but it's not
sympathy we want you know
anyone who can give you sympathy you
want the law changed
and you know talking telling him
everything basically what what we stand
for
and he was going yeah yeah i understand
that i understand that
it'd been so long i've not seen my
children i felt like i had it on my
shoulders for it was forever people
really to see their children and
maybe those are seeing their children
they wanted more time with their
children and maybe for the judges to
actually think hang on a minute
you know this has got to change
something's got to happen here
[Music]
i think i was up there for seven hours
and then me legs i could feel my legs
starting to go
everything sort of like was hitting me
at it all at once
i said okay i said look i'm starting to
get a bit tired now can i come down and
he said yeah by all means he said you
know you're going to be arrested i said
yeah that's fine
uh he couldn't be allowed to try and
edge his way back to the balcony or
indeed come down the way he got up so
they brought in a cherry picker
and he was escorted into
the cradle of the cherry picker and then
brought gently down to the ground where
he was promptly arrested
officials videoed every step of batman's
progress and a report's been sent to the
crown prosecution service will consider
bringing charges by the end of the year
i was arrested um
on suspicion of criminal damage yeah i
was uh hank huffed and obviously they
read me the rights and took me to
balmoral police station
two police officers come in and they
said they're from the serious crime unit
i had my sister if i'm chatting them
screaming down the phone at me saying
you've done it in a you're going to
prison for this you're going to prison
for this
and yeah i accepted that i accepted that
i might well go to prison for it
[Music]
and it was like a good cop bad cop
and he said let me put it to you
you scaled the walls of buckingham
palace
in a batman costume and i'm sat there in
a batman costume and he's got the front
page of a newspaper
[Music]
jason hatch the gloucestershire
decorator who stripped bare the cracks
in royal security reaps more of the
media storm his daring intrusions
whipped up
they never even went to call they just
turn around and drop the charges after a
night in police cells he was out and
heading for the scene of his alleged
crime
strained and tired looking he had to be
prompted into drawing attention to
fathers separated by law from their
children the trespass that that probably
even though it's uh the queen's probably
we actually pay as taxpayers
so that was my argument was that well i
could not be trespassed when actually i
actually own part of that because i pay
my taxes
jason what do you think you achieved
yesterday
public awareness
and hopefully my children have seen it
and they know that i haven't gone away
and i ain't going away
so i get to see my children and this law
is changed
to every father grandparent to see the
children
apparently enjoying the limelight hatch
was arrested after spending over five
hours close to the royal balcony of what
was supposed to be a week later
i had a call from my barrister saying um
we gotta go to london the world courts
of justice the following day
and i said well what for and she said i
don't know she said i've just had it
come through that we need to go and i
said ah okay
and there was lord faulkner there anyway
they come in they said
what would stop you from protesting
and i said i want to see my children
i said well like i've always asked for
every other weekend after school
holidays
um school reports uh stuff that that's
normally care
so he said yeah we're going to give you
that he said but
he said it's going to come with
something that you've got to give to us
and i said well what's that then he said
we've got to stop protesting we're going
to stick a 10-year asbo on you you're
not like no more than three meters off
the floor
and i said how is that going to work
when i'm painting decorator i work off
ladders
if anyone was encouraged by yesterday's
batman stunt
think twice before you go ahead
you risk being shot
at this current he had
generated enormous publicity
for himself and his own situation
and for fathers for justice generally
all dads who were having trouble getting
access to their kids
oh it set fathers of justice into outer
space i think we had about 12 000 new
members join up it just went wild to be
fair
they caught their public imagination
they were often cheered
during their protests and they were
either not charged at the end of them or
in some cases were acquitted by jurors
who clearly had some sympathy
for what they were doing
but in another way
it sort like
it died because obviously i couldn't
protest
and no one's sort of like took my place
then and therefore
i've not really had much of fathers for
justice ever since then
but it did prompt a debate even if it
didn't lead to any great changes in the
law
and it did
later much later
lead to some lifting of the secrecy of
family court hearings
[Music]
uh me
that coming protest was me getting to
see my children
again and being a dad
[Music]
i know they're all grown up i've got my
16 year old who's moved in with me
dad i want to move in with her and i
said okay you spoke to your mother yeah
so she lives here now with me
um i've got me eldest daughter she's 20
she's here all the time sunday dinners
dad can have some money dad cannot have
this
parents do
[Music]
i'm his son my son turns up here for his
tea
he's looking at a place to live now so
we're looking at places to live and uh
yeah it's sort of my children sort of
like um chuffed with what i've done
there you know because i
they thought they'd never seen me again
and now they've had a chance to see me
be with me of the last you know so many
years now and i've been there for him
done this for him
as a dad should do with the children
[Music]
so having achieved their aim of intense
publicity the dynamic duo returned home
leaving the police with the problem of
what to do with this ineffective barrier
and how to increase it without losing
the accessibility
[Music]
batman reigns buckingham palace was
produced by rob mulhern and tom
gillespie
more information on this episode go to
sky news dot com forward slash storycast
21.
storycast is multi-award-winning
storytelling podcast unit
next time
i remember after working
i went to library in bromley
and he stayed there choose the computer
internet
i have some breaking news coming from
the metropolitan police we understand
that there are reports that police
have
shot a suspected suicide bomber in
south london according to i read
the the police in london should
shoot to kill at a terrorist there have
been subsequent reports suggesting that
shots have been fired from a northern
line train this man was apparently taken
and we are hearing that uh shots were
fired
[Music]
you